he's an inventor electronics engineer
and computer programmer he was awarded
the National Medal of Technology and
inducted into the National Inventors
Hall of Fame he has an estimated net
worth of a hundred million dollars
he's Apple co-founder Steve Wozniak and
here are his top ten rules of success
boy this is the first time in years he
do this all for memories it's hard to
remember an old computer language I not
only designed this every little metal
trace that you see on here I strapped on
onto a drafting table and I built this
whole board myself because I wanted the
chips in the ultimate perfect position I
worked for a couple of weeks every night
till about 4:00 in the morning laying
out the little things on a big drafting
table that would eventually become this
board and when I got done I realized I
had to drill eight holes in the board
and I said you know what if I had only
designed it a little bit differently
then I would have only had five holes I
tore apart my entire design for another
two weeks every night till 4:00 in the
morning to get it just that perfect with
only five holes so you would never see
the three missing it had to be that
artistically perfect to me
because it represents yourself when you
do something when you do a great design
if my tips are don't necessarily think
that you have to have the homerun and
the huge Apple computer on your first
start I spent a long time in my life
with skills just building little devices
for fun for fun is one of the key things
because that drives you to think and
think and think and make it better and
better and better
than you ever would if you're doing it
for a company build things at first for
yourself that you would want if you're
going to build a retail or a real estate
business online well if you're not in
the real estate business you're not
going to really think about it the right
way you're building it for other people
that's what I say is wrong you should be
building it for yourself and if you're
not building it for yourself you better
have a tight partnership with somebody
that is that absolutely wants it for
themselves because they're going to want
it to be so perfect and so right and not
confusing and make it all the beauty
into the product I was so stunned
because I have very
dramatic memories of where I was when
the Beatles were on Ed Sullivan when I
heard that JFK had been shot and this on
you'll never get this memory out of my
head just where I was just getting a
phone call from a reporter and they just
said have you heard the news and I
instantly knew what that meant and that
was just a total shock like what do you
say it's like the world lost a John
Lennon I mean Steve was clearly the most
outstanding business thinker and almost
everybody who's high up in the
technology business recognized that that
somehow he had the ability to think out
new ways of doing things not just ways
to improve what we have do a better
version of something but do it in a
totally different way that the world
would swing towards and then I think
back to just all the times we had
together very very good times that you
have when you're young you know and
playing around with the systems and
Little Miss behavior and doing
interesting things and and then he was
always thinking about certain technology
the early products that got developed
the building parts what those might lead
to in our future and he was always
pushing me as an engineer could you
possibly add this someday could you
possibly add that someday yes yes yes I
could thinking no it's way way off but
eventually we all did we went into the
garage when we were two young people
with no money you have to work out of
your home we had jobs on the side we had
nobody that could loan us money we had
no business experience we're like a
million young people who are so excited
about the future they might have some
day in business making something just
out of their ideas that's what we work
over and over and over all the products
of Apple from you know iPhones and iPads
iPods these were just unbelievable life
changers and almost everyone who heads a
technology company looks at Steve Jobs
is where did he get the ideas to do it
the right way we were just the lucky
partnership he was lucky to have me in
the beginning but I am much you know
incredibly lucky to him for everything
in my life he gets a reputation for
being a strong leader and being brash
but to me he was just always so kind
such a good friend and I'm just gonna
miss him Steve Wozniak co-founder Apple
thank you very much
thank you
your actions you should always feel in
life in your jobs your actions are
somehow have a good purpose behind them
they better the world in some way don't
ever do something just because it's an
assignment you better believe that it's
do it there is some in the end goal that
is good for the world almost every new
invention and computer and all came
about from those ideals I mean I really
wanted to help the world communicate so
much you know other people inspired me
into a revolution I want to be a part of
changing things want to be a part of
better education won't be a part of the
young person having so much mastery over
technology and be able to do things they
never could before
those were the goods that were pushing
me it was almost almost without those
goods I wouldn't even design the
computer everywhere everyone likes to
talk about failures you know but the
main thing is you might have a lot of
little small steps every one of those
steps seemed to not take you anywhere in
money it didn't get you much more money
it didn't get any money but you know
you're kind of proud you show them off
to friends even your mind was increasing
your methods of coming up with better
solutions was increasing you not only
have to now read a book on how things
are done you can write the book and
that's called creativity you create new
things yourself so always try it here's
the biggest key I can give to anybody in
the world that if you're kind of smart
and you're working on some project maybe
it's software maybe it's hardware try to
think of the end you complete it you
know enough to complete it don't stop
there say how can I make it perfect
almost better than any other human being
would can I shorten the code can i redo
it a little cleaner structure give
yourself some of those redos and when
you're young you'll put in a lot more
than eight hours a day believe in
yourself you don't have to win arguments
you don't have to prove to somebody else
that you're right if you believe you're
right and everybody'll say no it's not
done this way you'll never make money at
it but you believe in it that's all that
that's what matters you know you got to
follow what's in your heart
and but the second piece of advice is
how far you go in life is usually I was
taught this when I was young and I
believe it
it's how well-liked you are by the
people you work with that will determine
how far you go up organization chart
ladders and the like so be nice to
people don't be cutting them down you
know don't be rude and all that stuff
you know it's just my philosophy the
talents that you have you're learning so
many formulas how to connect things how
to build devices the main thing is why
would you go through an education
learning how to design and create new
things and then go out and just try to
copy what exists always try to think for
yourself and think out better things and
were there before even don't be afraid
to go in different ways shai engineers I
think you have a huge advantage when you
come always want to have an instant
answer to everything you don't sit back
and reflect and think out the best
working solution taking everything into
account spend a lot of time on your own
call it dream time maybe when you're
just alone in a quiet room nobody else
with you falling asleep and and really
imagine the limits of where you can go
don't start building something until
you've gone very far and you know that
it's if you thought something out very
well that's ahead of what other people
are doing try to imagine yourself as the
best engineer in the world every one of
you try to think a little trick you can
do in your design could I do one thing
different having one thing that would
make me better that other engineers
wouldn't do and and also that's
basically a pursuit of excellence and
believe in your own ideas even if other
people are saying no it's not how it's
done it's too different well those very
different things are what are disruptive
and they wind up putting other companies
out of business and really changing our
life and your young engineer in college
weirded companies like Yahoo and Google
and Apple and Facebook and and you know
so many others where did they come from
they came from young people soft you
know young people dropping out of
college or just out of college these
days
entrepreneurship is taught as courses in
all the colleges and usually it's a
business level course so you've got all
these business guys that oh my gosh if I
write some ideas down on paper that's
how you go about it starting a company
and I my principle is know so many
people in Silicon Valley got used to
write ideas down on paper and then try
to get some money
try to get some money try to get some
money like we can just buy the
engineering for it no I like the type of
entrepreneurship that has actually
created working models here is an
example of something that works the way
we want it and we built it and we've got
the the talented the talented technical
people that know how to do it and I
think it should get to that phase so the
Entrepreneurship it's a combination of
the business and the technical doers the
technology people but it's things like
knowing who you are inside who you are
and believe it in that person and
remember the through life and saying
today it's a good person I am and I have
some good founders and a good hand on my
shoulders and I don't want to be
corrupted by the successes I'm going to
have in life and in business I don't
want to be corrupted and go in different
ways if I make a lot of money I still
want to be that good pure human who
thinks well like I said don't don't set
yourself up for those frowns you know
and you don't always have to win every
single argument you can think your way
and believe in your thoughts are good in
your own brain and somebody else doesn't
agree with you it's okay they just think
a different way there's no need to look
at the world of oh we've all got to be
in competition it's my way everyone has
to be just like me or they're no good
they have to use my computer they have
to go to my school they have to be my
country you know they have to do things
my way that's not the way the thing be
very open to a lot of different people
have differences and we can all still
see each other as good and we get along
a lot better and have a lot more peace
that way acceptance of others is the key
is life about how much you've done the
technology how much you've achieved how
much money you made in your life or is
life about how many times you laughed
compared to smile I would rather have a
happier life and sure if getting success
in business is what makes me happy
that's fine
but I really believe that you know some
kind of enjoyment aspect should go
through especially all learning and all
work now I was an engineer the work is
hard it's intense you work late hours at
night sometimes trying to solve a
problem you know and you just so hard to
get there and you finally crack through
and that sort of a relief but you know
what when you're working that hard
all day long you need those little jokes
with your friends you need the lunchtime
where you sit down and chat is such a
big part of your life thank you guys so
much for watching I made this video
because Jose Cruz asked me to so if
there's a famous entrepreneur that you
want me to profile next leave it in the
comments below and I'll see what I can
do I'd also love to know which of Steve
Wozniak's top 10 rules meant the most to
you you're going to start working on
leave it in the comments I'm going to
join the discussion thank you guys so
much for watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon